qui mieux que france 3 pour vous faire
vivre la folle journée du patrimoine
grâce à un dispositif exceptionnel
les 24 antennes régionales de france 3
se mobilise et vous emmène à travers
toutes les régions de france à la
découverte des trésors de notre pays
vous découvrirez des sites naturels
méconnu les architectures les plus
folles et vous rencontrerez celles et
ceux qui donnent vie à ce patrimoine
unique retrouver marie sophie lacarrau
pour la folle journée du patrimoine dès
10 heures 55
depuis bordeaux à 15h20 au château du
clos de vougeot en bourgogne puis à
20h20 devant la cathédrale de strasbourg
samedi en direct sur france 3